i'm so glad to introduce you to makeup
instagram god it's me and chad
hi everyone my name is man and i'm back
with a little
little makeup tutorial i'm gonna do a
fun kind of confetti inspired
eye look that is really a look you can
wear anywhere you can wear it out far
you can wear it
at home around your house in your
pajamas
base is done i am going to do a little
bit of eyelid primer
then i'm going to do a simple black
cat eye
so the way that i approach a cat eye is
i like to draw
the wing first one line
and then connect it to the rest of my
[Music]
eye
boom can i done
[Music]
so i'm going to take some paints
so i've got these danessa myricks
color fix pigments i'm going to take
these and the back of a brush so this is
a kj and huge spectrum collection brush
take a little bit onto the ring
and i'm going to use the back of the
brush to swirl in the color here
then i'm going to take it and generally
start applying in a kind of half hazard
wobby zombie kind of way
applying more pressure will make the
circle bigger
um applying less pressure will make it
smaller and you can also kind of
swirl the brush um
like this in a rotating motion to make
the
product more even once it's applied and
do a small little one of these
if you feel like you made a mistake
before the product dries take a little a
clean brush
and some micellar water and you can kind
of
correct those mistakes so
put the brush off then you can wipe your
ring off
and move on to another color i'm gonna
do
a primary blue
i don't want to do too much of the dark
blue so i'm going to move on
a little bit orange and then a little
bit of this
kind of like reddish color
all right last two colors i think
this green limesicle shade and beaches
which is my
favorite color from this line it's kind
of like a cerulean
boom
then finish it off with a lip liner
and i have this like color changing
blush by euphoria but i use it on my
lips
all right so this is the finished look
catch you guys next time bye
you